the coronavirus pandemic is reshaping
the biotech industry
investors are piling into small often
unproven companies
in hopes they can produce a vaccine in
the coming months those companies in
turn are spending big to expand
production
for vaccines that aren't yet fully
tested nor certified
it's a gamble on both sides for both
investor and company
and it reflects the urgency for a
vaccine as well as the potential
to make money german pharmaceutical
company curvac
20 years old 480 employees
and it dreams of changing the world it
has its sights set on the most sought
after of prizes
a coronavirus vaccine and the newly
listed company is making
progress when kurovac went public in new
york on friday
its shares rose 249 percent during the
first day of trading
those who got in early may have struck
it rich
qrvak is just one of many covered
vaccine hopefuls
170 companies from all over the world
including the us china japan the uk and
india are also in the race
last week russia claimed a breakthrough
president vladimir putin proudly
declared they were the first to approve
a vaccine
he said his own daughter had been
vaccinated
but scientists doubt the russian vaccine
named sputnik 5
is really ready
what's beyond doubt is that thanks to
high-tech methods used by the likes of
curavac
research is moving faster than ever
in normal times it would take 10 to 15
years to get a vaccine
to market now some companies have
reached the clinical trial phase in a
matter of months
regulators are expecting a breakthrough
as early as next year
no other product in the world has a
larger potential market
many nations have already placed orders
for hundreds of millions of doses
qrvak plans to produce a billion per
year if its vaccine comes to fruition
the question is whose will hit the
market first
and for more on this i'm joined now by
franz vernon he's ceo of kyravac
it's good to have you on the show when
will
good morning thank you when do you
expect your company to have a vaccine
ready for the public
and how much will it cost per dose
we are planning to have the vaccine
ready somewhere
mid next year depending certainly on the
data we are running clinical trial which
will be broadened
after first clinical data would we
expect in september october
and you know how much it works sorry
the the pricing at the end of the day it
will be
somewhere based on the cost of goods and
certainly all what went into the
technology which has been invested
into for the last 20 years in order to
make it happen but it should be
affordable
uh so you shouldn't overdo it with the
price there are certain settings already
done
we are on a very low base
cost of goods and that should be
reflected in the price there as well
so i would guess somewhere between 10
and 15 euros
10 and 15 euros are you already in
discussions with governments to supply
certain amounts of the vaccine
yes of course as we have got something
to offer and if you as you have seen
that governments
are doing this advanced purchase
agreements and certainly we are in
discussions as well
can you give us any names of the
governments that you're in discussions
with right now
well at the moment i can't sorry
your company is 20 years old and has yet
to bring a product to market
why do you believe it can deliver now in
such a short time
frame well the technology has been
developed during all these years in
order to get a technology in a
in a stage that you can really develop
products on it it takes a certain period
of time
and this mrna technology what we have
is very versatile so if you know the
virus
the sequence of the rice because we are
not working with the virus directly
but with the sequence of the nucleotide
sequence of the virus
and this is what we are coding on the
rna which has been in humans
and this is really a rapid development
certainly the rapid development is due
to the fact with regulatory authorities
as well that we are facing a pandemic
which needs certain requirements but
always taken
an eye on safety and security and
tolerability for the patient
so if i understand this correctly the
technology has improved the regulatory
environment has improved
but should we believe that mrna
therapies vaccines in this case
are going to suddenly they're going to
work in the next few months just because
the urgency is greater
or is there a chance that something
might fail during the larger phase three
test for example
of course the risk of development is
always there what
the rna can do is that you really fastly
can
code exactly the protein the wanted
protein for the very target on the rna
to produce it also rapidly
because this is a synthetic process for
the rna manufacturing
but it doesn't take the risk of product
development of course and this is why
you're running clinical trials
and there will be loads of data not only
with us but also other rna players
which are running clinical trials and
then you will see
what the data will bring and one should
not forget we are dealing with a virus
where nobody knows exactly
all the elements of the virus what you
need in order to be protected how long
you are protected it's a new virus but
the rna can really address due to the
fact that you can't develop rather
quickly on the basis of rna
to really have a vaccine and then to
test it and we should mention two of
those other firms
that are also working in this area
biontech moderna do you consider this a
race with other biotech firms
well first of all it is erased against
the time
there is a pandemic outbreak there with
huge effects on society nobody
you know doubts about this one and
therefore it's a race and
um not that much against the competitors
and at the moment and hopefully all of
those vaccines will work
there is a race also to have enough
capacity you always start in the
beginning and you can't cover
everyone and therefore it's good that
other players on the on the
in the game as well what kind of
pressure does that put on your company
to be raising capacity that is
production level
at the same time that you're building a
vaccine that you don't even know if it's
going to work or
achieve public approval how essential is
it that you get this right
well it is enormously essential for for
different
uh reasons first of all the company is
running for 20 years that's exactly
why the company has been founded to make
a difference to give a cure in a
situation like this one to be
fast versatile and of course safe and
horrible and
hopefully if the case is there as well
so it's a huge pressure it's a huge
pressure because
uh there is a pandemic situation out
there
and certainly everybody is looking to us
for good reason because we have got
something to offer and this is what we
have to prove so the pressure is there
but it is a positive pressure because
also our employees
have been working on it for all these
years exactly for this moment
to make it different and hopefully it
works out
the german government was an early
investor and you at the beginning of the
pandemic i should say 300 million euros
do you expect them to climb out now that
you've raised successfully so much more
money
well i certainly cannot talk for the
german government but the investment
there was a press conference also with
the minister of
economy is saying okay this is a
long-term investment
and they're in for several weeks now i
think this is not a long-term investment
there is so much more we can do because
it's not only about cobit
it's really changing the medicine today
and and put it on rna
in in different regards and oncology
protein therapies as well
all right that was franz berner haas ceo
of kirvak thank you so much for joining
us
thank you very much having me
you